stuntman Chads to helski is four years
younger than Keanu Reeves and has been
performing stunts for movies and TV
since 1993. early in his career he stood
in for Brandon Lee for reshoots of the
crow after Lee was accidentally killed
on set stahlski looks a bit like the
improbable love child of Alec Baldwin
and George Clooney but he got the job
doubling for Reeves in The Matrix
because his boss on another project
thought the two looked alike whatever
you think of their resemblance or lack
thereof the pair became a solid team
stahlski doubled for Reeves again on The
Replacements The Matrix Reloaded
Constantine and thumb sucker he also
coordinated the martial arts stunts for
The Matrix Revolutions after a long
career doing the stunts himself stahlski
mostly works as a stunt coordinator now
however he's also found time to occupy
the director's chair he's directed
Reeves in all four John Wick films and
has a slate of many more directing
projects in development